à mer Noire est devenu un enjeu majeur
de la guerre en Ukraine la Russie a
ciblé tôt ce matin mikolaïve et Odessa
de ville portuaires du sud de l'Ukraine
au moins 20 personnes ont été blessées
depuis le début de la guerre pardon le
début de la semaine c'est la troisième
nuit d'attaque sur Odessa et à s'inscrit
dans la nouvelle stratégie des Russes
Gulliver crack nous en dit plus
troisième nuit de suite de bombardements
ou tentatives de bombardement de ville
portuaire comme Odessa ou tchernomors et
puis cette nuit c'est mikolaïve qui
s'est rajouté à la liste nikolif qui
était une autre ville portuaire mais qui
n'avait jamais été inclus dans cette
fameuse ce fameux accord pour
l'exportation de grains
Ukrainiens par la voie maritime dans la
rue si c'est retirée il y a maintenant
trois jours à mikolaïve il y aurait des
morts selon le gouverneur régional sont
précisés le nombre et 9 blessés dont
cinq enfants au dessin la nuit dernière
il semblerait que les systèmes de
défense anti-aériens ukrainien ont
fonctionné un peu mieux que la nuit
précédente il y a tout de même des
dégâts dans la ville mais pas sur le
port comme ça avait été le cas il y a de
nuit clairement la Russie veut donner un
signal fort que elle ne veut pas que
l'Ukraine continue d'exporter les sans
sa participation à cet accord qu'elle
veut donner envoyer ce signal que ce
sera dangereux qu'elle a bien
l'intention de détruire que ce soit les
infrastructures ou même le grain je vous
rappelle qu'hier l'Ukraine a dit que au
moins 60
000 tonnes de grains avait été détruit
dans l'une de ces frappes sur le port de
Turner